okay first of all yes director what's up
what the IMAX cameras the boxing scenes
you've ruined me now I don't want to
watch Boxing any other kind of way
because it was just so good thank you
Jonathan said that you were such a
generous director what was that like for
you because in some scenes he's chewing
your head off but then you're going
behind the camera encouraging it so
what's that like for you it was fun you
know I I think uh you know he's such a
talented uh you know actor
um and you know for me all my you know
you know cash you know to be able to
kind of uplift them and put them in a
position to win especially for the
character you know calls for it you know
I think that's the fun part where you
know we're competitive people but we we
want the movie we want the scene to win
but in that scene you got two Alphas
that are going head to head so you know
respectfully we're we're going for it
you know but that's what's needed and
that's what's going to make the scene
better
um and so to have somebody to kind of go
back and forth with
um uh it's it's incredible it felt it
felt great given the Spirit of
competition and smack talk okay who is
the better boxer in real life you or
Jonathan can't compare you know what I'm
saying I I I can't you know and we're
very very competitive but you know you
know two different styles you know you
know Styles make fights you know I'm
saying you know that so so it's one of
those things where you know everybody
has a punches chance when it comes to uh
comes to boxing okay who had the most
gains physically
on this one thing Jonathan weighed a
little bit more to me so I'll say I
think Jonathan had more games me on this
one okay and
look because you love
you look okay but he has a cup
is consistent you know what I'm saying
he he uh you know depending on when he
wants to like throw it on he definitely
can do that I'm kind of the same way you
see me I'll be in I'll be in Swiss I've
been in director swag you know I'm
saying for the last couple years but
when I when I have to I'll uh I'll uh
I'll throw it on but I think tonight
we're all gonna bring it yeah yeah who
wins sexiest man alive in Creed Three
out of the two of you I'll give it to
Jonathan you give it to him for sure
what kind of smack talking is it you
guys are so nice to each other
Brotherhood man what it is brotherly
love right here man it's uh no I feel I
feel like I'm so excited for him you
know in this year that he's that he's
had and
um you know what's to come you know in
the future so you know I know what it
feels like you know so to have somebody
else that that's going through it and um
to play a small part in that Journey
it's it's so it's so gratifying like I I
understand what my directors feel now
when they would talk about you know me
as a cast member or other cast members
like how they just want to it's not
really so it's so not about us it's
really it's really about them yeah and
this film is an important moment for you
who in your life are you most excited to
see this film to see your work as a
director Mom and Dad yeah Mom and Dad
for sure you know yeah definitely
there's um you know I think you know
this is a love letter to a lot of
relationships that I have in my life you
know a lot of people that you know um
you know that I got a chance to
experience and be around and learn from
and uh and yeah so so for for the people
that know me the best this is like a you
know this is a love letter for for a lot
of them and I feel really I'm excited
for them to see it together yeah thank
you Michael thank you guys thank you
okay first off you were so fantastic in
this yes I want to see you I want to see
you play Joker
the joke The Joker that is like your
next roll sidebar wow I'm putting you on
to that I'm gonna call some people run
that okay run that right so like I like
the joke so in the spirit of competition
and smack talk with this film okay
who is the better boxer in real life you
or Michael Michael
really yeah just gave it to him who's a
better fighter who's me
um who's a better boxer Mike
ask Mike the same question if he doesn't
give me the fire to be okay yeah yeah
who had the most gains transforming for
this role you were Michael games yeah
games
like who got bigger yeah oh I think I
did I mean I think that's in the I'm I'm
the bigger man in general but that's not
that's not a matter of that's a
competition that's just it's supposed to
be smack talk Jonathan I can't it's hard
to smack talk your brother you know he's
on Facebook like your brother's like
yeah Michael B Jordan he's like he he's
got it yeah I mean he's been walking
around like that for ages you know I
think for me I was coming from I was
coming from a pilot film so I was quite
you know I was you know I couldn't fit
in the plane
um and so I was a bit more I felt uh not
as broad as he was yeah but we
together okay who is the bigger fashion
killer because me Michael liked to wear
a cardigan but she got the cup now yeah
you got the cup yeah I mean I mean I
don't think Mike would that's me yeah
that's me all the way
and sexiest man alive who wins it
Michael B Jordan
trash right are you supposed to be
talking oh me me me uh no that's Mike
it's Mike look at him I'm not super mom
yeah
it was fun watching you basically chew
his head off
what do you mean sexiest man alive
uh I don't know I think you got it John
wow I think you got it that's I think
you got in this film you yeah
in the film no but in the film you
Rivals everyone's Golden Boy in a way
that I was like wow okay this is
Jonathan's year respectfully but this is
not about me let's focus on something to
know this so it's good to know right
yeah okay appreciate it
um it was nice watching you chew off
Mike's head but then he was directing
those scenes so what was that like
having him as the Director oh wow it's
great I mean he um he's quite generous
you know he's very much a team player
you know that was the biggest
um
because insecurity in my mind where I
was like is he gonna let me run you know
for real for real not only did he let me
run he came in was like I mean he used
to do this you know and it just means
like get him you know and I'm like okay
like all right and I'm coming for you so
like all right if that's what you you
sure you know so he um
he might be a masochist you know because
he was he was he was gassing it you know
um I gave him the keys and he was like
do it bro and um that was great and that
just allows me to go even further you
know with certain things especially like
the Montage stuff that was probably the
most uh that's where he earned all my
respect as a director because what he
had to say to me you know that I didn't
I didn't do anything for for play you
know all the lifts were real or we never
changed oh that was real and so and we
shot it in one day and the body fatigues
you know and we were I remember flipping
that uh uh tire and him comes I need two
more bro
and I was I mean I mean it takes a lot
because I was I was out I was gassed and
like it was all and you know when I
flipped it for him you know and he said
two more you know and it was like the
way he we were chatting the way he was
guiding me through it you know I've
never had a director do that okay well
first of all I love what you bring to
these films just like emotional depth
you bring something that just feels
it brings it all together so for you
first day on set
was Michael nervous as director did you
see any signs of nerves yeah yes of
course because I know him so well yeah
but um but he also you know developed
the film for a year and and and and and
was rehearsing and getting in shape so I
think you know he's such a he has such
an incredible work ethic that I think he
was so prepared that he's you know he
you wouldn't necessarily be able to tell
him unless you know him very well like I
do yeah
um Jonathan is having an amazing year
yes what is that like for you watching
that it it's great I I remember I was
out at the Sundance Film Festival on the
jury the year that last black man in San
Francisco was there and he's tremendous
in that and I remember thinking like
this guy's such a star I'm so curious to
see what he does next yeah and I think
that's what's so cool about this
industry is you can think that and then
someone has you know a year where it
kind of all comes together so I'm very
proud of him and happy for him yeah for
your career being a part of this
franchise what moment or what are you
most proud of
uh over the course of my whole career I
I mean it's in this and like Creed what
would you say is like a moment that
you're like you know I'm most proud
about this aspect of being a part of
this franchise I think I'm proud you
know I've always been invited to be kind
of a co-author and so so much of what
Bianca is and what people seem to
respond to I've Been instrumental in
creating so I think that's something
that is a huge sense of Pride and now on
this one I feel like there's such
incredible representation that that Mila
provides you know for a whole community
and I think getting to be a part of that
is so you know is is incredible yeah in
the spirit of competition and smack talk
right Jonathan versus Michael
who is the better boxer in real life
I think Michael because Mike's been
doing it longer and he knows how to
float like a butterfly sting like
[Laughter]
information out of the two
I I think it's an unfair
I think it's an unfair thing because
Jonathan is just a bigger gentleman I
would say yeah and also I think Mike was
splitting directing look at me like a
like his like his his wife um he was
also splitting like directing and
preparing and so he wasn't able to be in
the gym in the same way that he has been
on previous films so yes I would say uh
what did they say in sports when it's a
draw or something okay
biggest Fashion Killer uh
uh I don't know I mean they're both
pretty fashionable you know I I think my
medicine I'm gonna say Mike I'll say
Mike it might be you and lastly
I just realized I'm like it might
actually be you well yeah I mean yeah I
think that's definitely true and lastly
sexiest man alive who wins that out of
the two
um
Mike has already won sexiest man alive
so there's that and I assume that
Jonathan will will win it at some point